alright so I'm here with Eric one of the
writers on portal 2 and is there
anything you can tell me about this game
that separates this game from the last
game how does this experience going to
be enhanced well the biggest difference
between four to one and portal two is
the co-op experience we've included a
full co-op track which is for two
players for set support or for portals
two sets portals and it's about twice as
long the co-op track by itself is about
twice as long as the first portal and
this envia single-player track is player
track there's obviously still a single
player campaign that is also about twice
as long as portal but they're two
separate tracks there's no different
story different puzzles completely
different sets of puzzles alright so
effectively it's about four times longer
than the first portal about four times
as long um how is a have you listened a
fan feedback is there anything that
people said like hey I'd like to see
this in Portal 2 that you guys were like
hey I think that'd be good too well the
biggest thing it goes back to coop again
we heard from lots and lots of people
that they somehow managed to play portal
1 co-opted Lee it was just a game where
there's almost like a kind of gateway
drug for people who play games would
kind of rope their friends in who didn't
play games or their boyfriend girlfriend
parents whatever and they would sort of
sit together and actually play it with
the gamer Manning the control and we
just wanted to get a controller into
that second person's hand and let them
you know share in the experience more
fully so hopefully your friend actually
has a brain too when can we expect this
game to be released it'll be out of
februari 9 2011 on PC Mac xbox 360 and
the ps3 covering the whole board alright
man thanks a lot for your time I really
appreciate it